wait thank you yeah just uh let's wait
for a couple of more minutes maybe
someone will join in and if not that's
also fine
yeah thank you
yeah so if you want to check it out it's
brics.com.ai maybe I can make it a
little larger but I don't think it will
enlarge in the bar on top
hmm
but okay
all right should I start then yeah I
think we can start now okay then then
let's go get going a warm welcome from
my side as well uh yeah I'm I'm Leonard
and very happy to have you all here also
welcome to people who are
um watching online
um so today I'm going to show you our
really cool open source tool which is
called bricks it's an open source
Content Library for natural language
processing and in bricks you can find a
lot of really useful modular components
to transform or to enrich
or to and extract data from from your
texts
first of all a short question who of you
has some level of expertise in natural
language processing any of you okay
some okay that's that's right that's
that's totally fine I'm going to keep
this talk relatively basic so if you
don't have any domain knowledge in NLP
or just very little that's totally fine
you should probably be able to tag along
just fine
so let me maybe start with a short
outline of today's session what we're
going to look at today we just did the
introduction part very nice next I'm
going to show you around in our open
source tour going to show you what you
can do and what the cool features of our
tool are
after that I'm going to tell you how our
modular components which we call Brick
how they are structured and why they are
structured in the way that they are and
how we basically build all of these
modular components
then after that we're going to head over
to our GitHub page where you can find
all the source code for our tool and
where you can also find a whole lot of
ideas for new components or you can find
Pages for the modular components that
have already been integrated in the past
and we're going to pick a cool use case
that we can then later on integrate
together so we're going to build a new
brick module together today as well
all right after that we're going to do
some we're going to check out some
prerequisites what you need if you want
to contribute if you want to build such
a module yourself it's very easy it's
very simple
we're then going to do some standard
development things like setting up a
virtual environment and installing
requirements
um all
um that's a kind of thing
after that we're going to write some
code going to test out some ideas and
then we're going to embed a brick module
into an endpoint service what that is
all about I'm going to show you later on
but it's a very important feature of a
brick module
then we're going to add a code snippet
that users can then copy from bricks and
then embed into their own projects so
another very important step and as with
any software we also need to write some
documentation then as well and set some
configuration so that everything's
working fine and after that of course
some further testing to ensure that
everything works well and that
everything is set up as intended then
we're going to create a pull request and
hopefully at the end have a new working
component for our open source Content
Library and yeah have great success
cool before we jump into some code
um allow me to show you some of our
brick modules so our Content Library is
is divided into three larger sections
the first one being
classifiers so the name here is very
self-explanatory I would say so whenever
you have some text input where you for
example want to get the sentiment from
or you want to find out if the text
contains any profanity
if you want to find out how subjective
is it is then you can use these
components to classify your texts
so for example here we have a specific
sentiment classifier and on the upper
right of each brick component you have a
small window if I maybe enlarge it we
can see it a little better and here this
is really your playground to test all of
these models out and to see if it's the
right one for you here for example we
have a an example input saying World
Peace announced by the United Nations
that is very obviously very positive so
if we run that brick module it says okay
yeah it's positive but sometimes you
maybe have cases where it's not that
obvious and you want to try out if the
module is working as you think it does
then you can try it out here so I can
put something else in here like pycon is
really cool with lots of nice people can
try that out as well and it's obviously
again a positive sentiment again
but I can also try it out with a
negative sentence like the coffee
was really bad and it started
to rain or no and let's see what the
sentiment classifier thinks about this
and I would say it's negative yeah I
agree so let's say you scrape some some
data from Twitter social media
you have a question right there
yeah let's let's find that out I would
guess it would then return a neutral
sentiment but let's find out so what was
the sentence pycon is really whoops
really great but the people are nasty
those are not my words by the way I
don't agree this is just for testing
purposes
then it would say yeah it's negative so
that's overweighing again this is just
one of the sentiment classifiers that
you can use and if you say okay this one
is not accurate enough for me then yeah
you can try it out another one but you
don't have to integrate anything into
your environment or something you can
test it out right here
but if you say okay this module looks
really cool I want to to use it
then you have the source code available
right here you can just copy paste the
snippet we also always provide an
example implementation so that you get
some examples to try it out on and yeah
you can basically just copy paste this
and run it and see how it works as well
and directly integrate it then into your
project
yes of course
Vader yes
so Vader this is not like only for Star
Wars content or something but no Vader
is like the name of the algorithm that
we use in this specific brick module so
Vader stands for it it's right here it
stands for a valence aware dictionary
sentiment Reasoner so it's a rule-based
system that's basically looking at all
the words in the
um in the text and then determining the
sentiment of the text but we also have
other components that work a little
differently yes please
next around
uh I'm not entirely sure
um how it does it but I would guess here
that it's like counting all the words in
a Text corpus and then also tries to do
some context space matching but it's not
as good like a GPT model or something
like if you need a really robust model
then this is not the way to go but it's
very lightweight and for a lot of use
cases it's really good so yeah and I
think sentiment classification is also
like a tangible use case it's kind of
easy to understand
okay but we don't only have brick
modules for classification we also have
things to do extraction so whenever you
want to retrieve certain entities from a
text Data like for example addresses
codes certain numbers credit card number
States you can use the brick modules for
that as well so for example I have here
a module for date extraction and I have
a text with a lot of different dates and
if I run it the extraction modules will
then return the position in which it
found the entities so that I can then
later work with it we do it in that way
because we use a lot of Spacey for our
work in NLP so if you don't know Spacey
it's a very popular library for natural
language processing and if we have the
position of the extracted values we can
then use these to then further down the
road
process them with the Spacey Library
okay
and last but not least if you're not
doing any classification on if you're
not doing any extraction work you're
probably dealing with a generator so
with the generators you can do cool
things like uh for example language
translation basically whenever you have
some form of input and the input is
changed and you have a different output
like language translation you can do
search with Google or Bing using these
modules you can clean your text data so
if you have a lot of HTML fragments in
your data then you can use some of these
modules as well
and yeah that's that's basically the
generators in a nutshell
all right
um very cool
so any questions so far or
should I should I move on okay
he has a right
yes
absolutely okay maybe let me get back to
the Vader's sentiment classifier
um so the difference between just a
simple code snippet and like a brick
module as we call it
um it's not only that we have this
playground but we have like the whole
open source
um let's say platform behind it
so when I click on the GitHub button
that every brick module has it will take
me to the dedicated issue page on a
GitHub that every of our components has
basically the process is that if you
have any idea for a new module for a new
brick component you write down your idea
and say okay I want to do this I want to
do that maybe you already have a draft
or first version of the code that you
would like to share where you say okay I
can do this with this code you don't
have to provide any code but you can
always of course share it here as well
and you can also provide some additional
context here
for example share a certain python
library that you found or an article it
could be anything that could be used to
then build this component then and the
great thing about the GitHub Pages here
is that you can also use them to ask
questions for example here my colleague
Johannes he was not really sure about
how to use this sentiment classifier he
was not really sure
um how it's how it's working and he just
um could use GitHub then to ask a
question you can also use the page here
to say okay it contains a bug or it can
be improved by doing something
and then you have this platform to talk
about
okay before we jump into all the ideas
that are currently open maybe let me
tell you how all of these models all of
the modules are currently structured
so to build a brick module we need at
least four files here
first we need a file called init.pi and
this is basically containing all the
code that you see that is run when we
run the example input so this is not
computed locally or something this is
like running on an endpoint service that
we provide and all of this code is then
contained in the init.pi file
then we also need a file for the code
snippet that you then have here oops
where's my mouse
that you see here and the code in the
code snippet that the user then sees is
a little bit different than
um the code for the actual endpoint that
you can then run
um and so these need to be in different
files and also we store the code snippet
in a markdown file we don't want it to
be executable so that's fine and it's
also way easier for us to pass and then
put in our content management system
otherwise this would be just a normal
python file or something
then we also have a config file nothing
wild going on here either just to for
example set the links for the GitHub
Pages or the um
or like hashtags we have that we also
recently included a batch if a brick
module is gdpr compliant or not not
really that important for say private
users
but if you are a company then this might
be a really good information to have if
a module is using some sort of API for
example and you don't know really where
the data is going then you maybe
shouldn't use that component then
and last but not least some
documentation in the readme file which
ends up
um here at the top where you basically
can say how to use this module if
there's anything special you need to
keep in mind when using it some sources
what library was used these things
cool and optionally we also provide
always a second code snippet which is
based on Spacey for all the modules we
do this because we use Spacey a lot so
the library for NLP I mentioned earlier
we use that in our tools and our other
tools a lot and so to ensure that you
can use all the brick modules in our
other tools we provided as well but I'm
going to skip that for today you don't
really need to work on that it's totally
optional if you like to include that
then feel free to do so but you totally
don't have to
yes of course always
roughly yes so the actual code that is
run on the text data is the same but
everything around that is a little bit
different I'll
um talk more about this later on but
it's similar
yes so
um all the brick modules they take in a
normal string as an input and that is
not the case for the code that we use
with Spacey so all these Spacey code
Snippets they expect a Spacey document
as an input basically that's already a
little bit pre-processed and we do that
so we can later down the road do a
little bit of more processing
um but yeah the the only difference is
really the input that the um that the
function is then expecting
and uh
yeah to avoid that you always need to
create the Spacey input yourself we also
provide like a regular python input
if that's a little bit clearer now
okay cool
then we have that
um what are the prerequisites if you
would like to build one of these models
your own on your own it's very easy you
only need python I mean we're at pycon
what a surprise
you need a git and GitHub of course to
be able to create an issue for all the
modules you need our GitHub repository
which you can simply clone in the future
we might include a pip command as well
so that you can just pip install bricks
but we haven't done that so far and of
course I think it's always important to
have fun when working on things like
open source because otherwise what's the
point
um so yeah not really a prerequisite but
I highly highly recommend it
okay
then
um I'm going to jump right back into
GitHub where we have an issue page if
you would like to check out our GitHub
page it's github.com code minus current
minus AI slash bricks and here you can
find all the source code for all these
components as well so if you would like
to use them in your own projects you
have
that accessible here
and you can also check the issue page
where we have some
ideas open for Brick modules that
haven't been implemented yet so for
example one of our community members he
said okay I want to build a frame I want
to build a brick module that is able to
detect what Frameworks are mentioned in
a text for example or my colleague
Johannes he's he suggested to build a
brick module for OCR auto corrections so
really cool things
and I recently stumbled upon a very cool
Library which is called a sumi or Sami
which you can use to well summarize
texts and works really really well
and it's also very easy to use so I
think I'm going to use that one to then
build a brick module also have provided
some of the code here as well and so we
can take that and then build a brick out
of that
it's not going to be as good as like
again a GPT model but it's again very
lightweight very easy solution and it's
also free so I think it's worth building
a module of a module out of that
and the special thing also is that I
want to use this library to summarize
um uh websites so I don't want to have
an uh whole text as an input but I want
to First scrape some data for example
from a block article or from Wikipedia
to then get a summary of a website and
to do that I'm going to use the
Wikipedia page for capybadas if you
don't know copy balas very cute animals
really really like them and I think I'm
not the only one who likes kabibatas
because the text for them is really long
so people people seem to really like
them but maybe I don't have the time to
read all of that
and then I might be using the module
okay I'm going to refill my glass of
water and then we can jump into some
codes
okay
are there any questions already or maybe
online
so
you can also use slido to post the
questions
from the session before okay now I can't
answer those I can try but yeah we'll
archive them I think someone should be
yeah
okay
um so if you like you can tag along but
of course you don't have to to develop
I'm not going to use Windows
I'm going to use what's called a Windows
subsystem for Linux so basically I have
a Linux kernel running inside of my
windows
yeah OS so I'm going to use that to
actually build
the module
so first what you would do then of
course is go to our really cool GitHub
page
and then clone the repository so you do
like git clone and do that I already
have the repository on my machine so I'm
not going to execute that instead I'm
going to head over
to the Repository
then what you would do is create for
example
a virtual environment with conda I'm
always using the built-in tool from
Python and then create a virtual
environment already have done that as
well let's activate that
cool and then you would pip
install
all the requirements because there are
quite some
oops
requirements
60.
yes you can see I came prepared and yeah
don't have to download everything
cool let's um open up uh the directory
or the bricks
with Visual Studio code I'm using visual
Visual Studio code you can use other
Ides of course as well or code editors
I think it's a little bit small right
hard to see maybe I can enlarge it a
little bit
I hope
tap size
is that better no I think this just
increases the side of size of the code
right
foreign
font size where you have that
oh yeah it's only increasing the font
size
I don't know
um okay I'll guess I'll just explain
what what you can see here so just like
you have on the front and side
um the three categories of classifiers
extractors and generators you have the
basically the same structure in the code
the underlying code so we have one
folder containing all the classifiers
and you have one folder containing all
the extractors and one folder for the
generators and then each of these
folders We group bricks biological
structures so for example if we have
multiple brick modules for sentiment
classification they would then go into a
folder called sentiment where we have
like the Veda sentiment classifier we
saw earlier and another sentiment
classifier that you can use and so on
and if you want to contribute a brick
module you can either search for a
directory if it's already existing and
fitting to the use case that you have or
you can of course feel free to create a
new directory and put your brick module
in there then
so we want to build a brick module that
is able to summarize texts and so we
have some form of input in our case
that's an URL to a website and we want
to get as a result the summarized text
of that website so our brick module
would fall into the category of
summarization
and we already have some modules for
summarization for example we have one
module you can use to remove small talk
from texts basically it's trying to look
at how many stop words are in a given
sentence and then removes sentences that
only consist out of stop words
um we have another brick module for just
summarizing normal texts
and now I want to build a brick module
to summarize websites
like in every good cooking show I also
came prepared
so I prepared something we already have
the init.pi file to some degree at least
which will run the code that is hosted
on our endpoint you can see the actual
function is still missing we're going to
build that together later on and I'm
going to explain what we need this for
then we have the code snippet which also
requires a little bit of a certain
structure here again the actual function
code is still missing going to build
that two together then the config and
the readme is also still empty and we're
going to fill that with live as well
so maybe let's start with the init.pi
file
what's important about this file is that
you need to ensure that the input that
the function receives is in a certain
format and for that we're using a
library called pedantic if you don't
know what pedantic is maybe you do I
think we also had some sessions at pycon
about pedantic it's a library in a
nutshell to ensure that the format of
the input that we receive for example
for a web service is in a certain format
and that's all we do here really we
import the base model function the base
model class from pedantic and then pass
that to a specific function for our
brick module then our case that is
called the Sumi website summarizer model
and here we lay out the whole expected
input so we of course expect a URL it
should be a string we can set the
language of the text that we want to
summarize in our case we have defaulted
that to English but you can also then
use it to summarize like German texts or
whatever other languages the Sami
Library supports
and we also have a parameter for the
sentence card sentence count
um basically that's the length of the
summary so if I set this to five then we
have five sentences in our summary if I
set this to 10 it would be a little bit
longer
right and then we pass that Sumi website
summarizer model into our actual
function and here we can then retrieve
the information from that from that
class
so I'm going to do that
we also need to include some Doc strings
before we get to coding So yeah thank
you GitHub co-pilot
this is just a small a short summary
that will then be displayed in the
actual website
here
under the name of the function so that
we have a very short description of what
the module is able to do
cool and then after that we first set up
a parser because the difference with
this summarization model and the other
ones is that we first want to scrape
data from the internet
like Wikipedia or blog article luckily
Sumi has a built-in function for that so
that we can just pass HTML from a URL
we put in a tokenizer which will then
pre-process a little bit the described
data
after that we're also going to use
something called a stemmer if you don't
know what a stemmer is a stemmer returns
a word like for example doing to its
space form so doing would then be
converted into the word do
and the stemma tries to do this for all
the words so that we don't have like
duplicates because doing and do would
otherwise be counted as two words but we
want to treat it as one word that's what
the stemma in a nutshell is doing
then we actually instantiate our
summarizer past this summer to our
summarizer
and we also remove stop words because
how Sumi is working under the hood it's
also counting how many stop words for
example are there it's a little bit more
than that but it's not super complicated
but we also need to remove the stop
words of the language that we want to
summarize
yeah then the summarizer gets a document
and after that I think we need to do
some list comprehension
because
um
I think this is not completely right
yeah this should be right because the
summary is then a list
of tuples which contain the extracted
sentences and we need to put that
together so that we can get a normal
text as an output
okay
that's really it that's the whole code
we need for
um for our brick module to be able to
run in the
um on the example input side it's only
29 lines of code so
very easy here no rocket science needed
I'm going to going to try out yeah if
you have questions
it's a third-party Library oh yeah maybe
I should have
[Music]
um
spoken in more detail about that yeah
it's a it's a library you can find on
GitHub we can take a look at the library
I think I have posted the link here as
well
so on the Discord Channel actually there
is a room for where this tutorial is
happening and there I am also updating
the links which are mentioned in the
talk so on the Discord Channel
yeah you can for example find it on the
Discord or just Google uh Sumi then you
can go to the page on GitHub
it's quite popular so it has a lot of
stars and it's a very lightweight again
and yeah it's not something from bricks
itself so it's just a third-party open
source Library we're also using in this
case for our brick module as well we
could have built this ourselves but yeah
basic questioning to say that if someone
else uses
yes they have to install something first
yes
it will if you clone our repository and
then do a pip install requirements it
will then because we will add summary
then also to the requirements of bricks
and then you should be able to run all
brick modules so yeah maybe you can show
it in your requirements file
well haven't implemented yet but yeah we
have a file called requirements here I
think txt here are all the requirements
needed for bricks and if we want to add
then the new brick module using Sumi we
would then add I don't know Sumi
0.9
0.9 and then save that and then commit
that as well
so yeah but a good question
okay
um we now have the init.pi ready we're
going to test it out later on as well or
we can test it out now
um before we then finish up with the
code snippet
um because we use pedantic to check the
input we can't just hit run and run this
script to see if it's working what we
need to do is we need to kind of
simulate
um this and kind of treat it like it's
already running in the actual endpoint
because
um yeah this is not then executed
locally but in a remote web service and
to do that we're using fast API
um and you can simply spin everything up
again fast API should also be already
installed if you install all the
requirements and you can spin up that
service by running uvcorn API
API and do a Reload
so that if we make changes it will then
restart the service
and then if we go to localhost
8000 Docs
we then have a graphical user interface
this is again nothing from bricks itself
this is provided by fast API so the
service we use to then access the
the components and then we can search
for Sumi it's not here because we also
need to add the name of the function
uh into another init file so each of the
so the generator the classifier and the
extractors they also have an init file
and here we need to First import that
component so that fast API is able to
find that that's why we also need to
name it init.pi so that it gets
recognized as a name package
and here we also have the other
sentiment summarization modules just
going to add that here
and now fast API should restart
and then we should be able to test it
out and hopefully it directly works
okay let's go back to fast API search
for maybe reload the page
it's not here that's
uh
I've got something
all right let's retry again
fast API should be restarting
applications startup complete let's load
again
cool and here it is so we are now able
to use the code we just wrote via an API
and thankfully fast API is really great
to use and we have the ability to try it
out
here we already have the schema that we
have supplied so earlier in the code we
have provided like the schema here and
this is what we can then see here
now let's grab our
link to the copybara page
and see if it's actually working fingers
crossed if not that's also fine
yeah and it's actually working so we
have set the sentence count to five so
um our module has now
summarize the whole Wikipedia page for
kabibatas which is quite long into just
five sentences you can go over it okay
they have some different names in other
countries we have some sources here
which are probably not that necessary
for all summarization but yeah and it
was also super quick I mean I can try to
run it again
and it probably just takes like a second
or so so it's a really
um easy and lightweight solution to
summarize your texts yeah I mean GPT
would be probably a lot better but also
more expensive and
you can't run it on your local machine
so that's great
that's then the part for the endpoint
service we can close fast API here again
that is all fine that's working let's
maybe spend some time in the code
snippet file that the user will then be
actually able to execute
um I have prepared some of the code here
already in the markdon file and because
we can't develop the markdown file maybe
we need to change it in the future
um but yeah ideally you can test it out
in a Jupiter notebook or a normal python
script whatever you feel comfortable
developing in
I'm going to use a jupyter notebook for
this today
and really the difference is that we
don't need to use the pedantic base
model we also have the import statements
here and also again the function in the
code snippet is expecting a different
input than the function in the init file
so here we need to set all the
parameters we also ask every contributor
to include some typing so that you know
what data type is expected for the
inputs and that you should also type the
output so in this case everything is a
string no the sentence count should be
an integer
cool and ideally you should also provide
some documentation you can simply
you know say about the params are doing
so the URL is the URL of the website you
want to have summarized then we need to
set the language of course sentence
count
nothing crazy here
and yeah then we basically do the same
thing we did as with our init file for
the endpoint we instantiate the parcel
to scrape the data from the website oops
then set up the stemma to then return
words to their base form
summarize everything I'm happy that I
have GitHub co-pilot I don't need to do
anything really
um yeah extract is stop words
create a summary of our text and after
that do some
joining and some
yes joining and some list comprehension
and that's our brick module what we also
always ask users to provide in the code
snippet is an example implementation and
we quite clearly divide both so the
actual implementation in code and some
example integration if you want to use
this brick module you don't really need
the example integration but it's really
great to provide that for every brick so
that users can directly see okay what is
an example how can the inputs from that
function look like so that you can
directly use it so if we then execute
this
okay it took about 2.3 seconds or not
too bad and then yeah you have basically
the same output as you had in the fast
API dashboard so the summarize text here
nothing crazy it's a little bit uh
greatly formatted but yeah we have that
working as well then we can simply
copy all of it
cool paste it into the code snippet so
that the users will then be able to see
it on the brics website
and that's almost
all there is to it then we need to
configure some configuration
for that I'm just going to a template
folder that we have here as well
and grab some of the code you don't need
all of it
implement it as well here
so what configuration do we need to
provide for our brick module of course
we need the name so the name is Sumi
website summarizer
oops
put that in here we then also have a
field for the issue ID we need that so
that on bricks itself
we can get a link to the GitHub page so
this is then what you will see
um up here if you press the button it
will basically direct you to the issue
page
and we have already created one for our
brick module that we are working on see
number 284
um then you can also set like an icon
but that's not too important here at the
moment as well some minimum required
version for our other tools also not too
important
the type is probably a little bit more
important because if you're using some
form of API that you need to pay for we
need to set this as a premium brick so
we let the users know that if you need
to to pay for a service that is running
in the background then you can see that
it is a premium model but we are not
using anything
um like this in our case so you can just
leave it as a normal python function
also flag for gdpr compliance I would
say it's also totally fine
and yeah that's really all we need to
configure
and then for the readme we can also
write a short description like this uh
brick module is using
the Sumi library from
GitHub to summarize texts that
that were
scraped
from
websites like Wikipedia or blog articles
oops
blog articles
okay then we might also include
the link to the
third party library that we use
so that people can jump into some
documentation there if they like
cool save everything and that's
basically it you would then of course
to your git at and get
commit
edit module for summarizing
websites
push that oops
and
I'm going to create a new Branch you
probably then would have to Fork it but
it's
very similar then
okay yeah then you can open up a pull
request
say okay I have built this really cool
module to oh this is not my
my library oops
yeah open up a new pull request for the
pycon branch I have created and then ask
some of my co-workers for example to
look over it then it gets joined and
then you can already use it on our brick
service
yeah
that's really it and we now have a cool
new brick module
all right
um
thank you I guess if you have any
questions then feel free to ask and also
like come to me after the session if you
like and yeah thank you for your
attention and I hope you enjoyed it we
can do the questions I mean there will
be Hands-On session after this right
or we are done with the Hands-On session
yeah yeah let's
oh wow
are they I was a little bit fast I think
sorry
okay we have a lot of time for the
discussions almost yeah feel free
are there any questions anyone wants to
start
do you have any questions
yeah yeah great
well it's uh I would like to ask you if
you could come back to the moment where
you
um added the first API yes line in the
Swagger yes because it was kind of magic
like okay in three seconds the theme was
there okay yeah sorry I think I rushed
through a little bit so where did I miss
you when I started up The Fast API
service so you could you create the code
you have the functions there
and now you use the
you put the API up
with ubicorn yes yes but first API was
kind of nowhere but still it was the
okay packing up the whole thing I think
I guess yes sure so yeah you're
completely right we have put all the
code here in the init.pi file and then
we start up fast API with the UV current
command so if we type in UV corn
API again we don't need to set up
anything else all the rest is handled by
by bricks we have already set up
everything in the tool itself
and then we just need to
um yeah start fast API with this command
this will spin up everything that we
have
we don't need to do anything more really
it's downloading everything that it
needs setting up everything that it
needs all of that is handled by by
bricks and now we have that running
locally on our computer just to test it
out but in theory that is exactly the
same thing that would then happen on a
server in the cloud to then execute all
the code for the actual website bricks
okay is it a little bit more clear or
yeah yeah okay and yeah after we have
started then fast API we can go to
localhost
8000 slash docs where we then have a
graphical user interface where we can
test out everything so this is basically
like one layer below the actual brics
website you can maybe say
so
so what we can test out here on
on the fast API
that is basically the same thing that we
were that we're pushing like into the
example input here and the same thing we
would get as an endpoint response here
so this is like just a layer on top of
of everything
but because we don't want to like clone
the front end and everything as well we
use fast API for this
yeah I have a question
um maybe it's me being dense how do I
actually use a brick
in in practice yeah sure
so what you can do is you can call the
endpoint directly so you can
um like call the URL of the actual brick
or what you can do is you can simply
copy the code snippet that you have here
so if you say this is actually a
functionality that I would like to
implement in my own project can simply
copy the code implement it in your
project and then use it right away
so these are the two two options you
have
yes because yeah please sorry
so um thank you very much
um I know that you also have this
product Refinery yeah you basically can
um yeah enhance your data and stuff and
I think that well at least I thought
that the idea of Pricks is also a little
bit enhancing this with having modular
systems and stuff it is yeah it's kind
of both so all the bricks we have you
can use them in Refinery as well so
Refinery is another tool of current that
you can use to label your data to
transform data you have and you can use
all the brick modules that we have in
our other tools as well but you don't
need to so if you just have some normal
NLP project and you would just like to
go hunting for some cool code Snippets
that's also totally fine so you don't
need to use these brick modules in our
other products but you of course always
have the um the possibility to do so
yeah so it's kind of for both
can you explain the AV con is it is it
also part of the bricks itself it's just
loading the fast API right it's only the
deployment of the API yeah exactly so
here on the live website we have a like
a web service a server running and that
server has fast API loaded in all the
endpoints are ready to go and whenever
you call an endpoint it just executes
the code that we have written and then
provides you with the output
and if people wants to do Hands-On can
they start is there any yes a link which
you could post so that they can start
working on special yes so everything I
basically told you you have also on our
GitHub repository we have a lot of
videos on our YouTube channel where you
can check that out
um as well we have a file called
contributing.md in our GitHub repository
repository as well where you have a long
and detailed description of all the
steps you need to take to contribute
where all of the files are then also
explained and where you can then do this
yourself then too
yes so everything you need is already in
our repository and yeah no one can stop
you from building a brick then
okay
can you pip install bricks like pip
install bricks and then not yet
okay but we will definitely Implement
that in the future so that you can
simply pip install bricks and then have
everything ready to go
so I would be able to use like 10 bricks
like struct address extract numbers
threat yes and you will then yeah and
you will then be able to also import a
brick as a class so for example like
here the summarization
brick you could then import like a
normal class like pip install bricks and
then from bricks and import uh like uh
summarize website whatever yes but yeah
it's work in progress but something that
will come in the future
cool
sorry I mean you were saying we can run
it from
um using a URL but if I look at the
brick for cosine similarity in in the
list of bricks there's no indication how
to call that using an API yes so what
you would need to do is
um we don't have it written out in the
documentation so
um but what you can do is you can call
the content management system that we
have set up for bricks and then
basically say Okay I want a classy fire
and then the name of the the bricks or
for example Veda sentiment
classifier and then include the data in
the URL here as well
but yeah I didn't prepare that because
that wasn't a really uh part of the
session but it's definitely possible
but that being said it's also just meant
for playing around but we are thinking
about
um setting this up for production
workloads in the future as well so that
you can also pass a lot of data through
that as well
is it in production like are there any
examples in the production use case
yeah so um as I previously mentioned we
also use these bricks and other tools of
us like our main tool which is called
current AI Refinery and yeah a lot of
our customers are using these brick
modules
um to then process data transform data
and Rich data and uh yeah so far we have
found them very very useful
when you plan to make it as an python
like in package
can't can't really say it at the moment
as soon as possible definitely but yeah
so need some more time so you have one
of the core developer after yes yes I'm
one of the Developers for for bricks I'm
mainly spending my time working on this
okay
and he said uh how do how do people
start contributing is it easier or do
you have like a much layer or is it only
exclusively for your own company people
too no everyone everyone is open to
contribute it's basically everything I
just showed you that's it to contribute
a brick module
um and you don't even have to contribute
a whole module what you can also do is
you can go to our GitHub page and then
simply open an issue so if you have an
idea for a new module but you're maybe
not really sure if it's a good idea or
can be really useful just share your
idea on our GitHub page and then we can
maybe take a look at it or maybe you
have some implementation but you need
feedback on to really make it work and
you can post that here as well so you
don't even need to contribute whole
modules
um we are happy for for everything
are there any more questions or
um when you use the brick with Spacey
did you do something else than
classifying span text and labeling the
span text
is there any other use case or way to
use Spacey
um yeah there are a lot of use cases for
space as well which could probably fill
a whole session on its own
um but really we use it to tokenize the
text and then pre-process it further
down the road
um so that's really all of it gets to it
for us at least but what I mean is that
when you do astruction of for instance
dates in books yes when you use Spacey
you you create a document Where the
dates are labeled I guess and you can
label them with spacey but the way we
use it is we have like uh imagine you
have a sentence and then when we
tokenize it with Spacey you have like a
list where every word is like a part of
this list and you have kind of like an
index for that then and so we can use
the output of the extraction modules for
example here to find out the position of
the extracted
dates in this example that makes sense
yeah yeah okay
I like to make
okay anything else
well
okay
so if not I think we can end the session
cool uh thank you very much we would
like to thank the speaker again Leonard
thank you
where would you put your notion link uh
I can add it to our GitHub page if you
want
um apart from that everything you need
to know like the requirements the steps
to contribute they are already on GitHub
so you will find everything else there
so and I can also share it on the
Discord side of pycon if you like yeah
in the pycon there is a channel for the
room and there I posted some links and
you can also put the uh the notion link
so that they can have access yeah sure I
will post everything there then as well
so I think that ends the tutorial
session it was quite fast and quite cool
and so I think there's going to be a
closing session at the coupons also
please do attend it and yeah thank you
for attending yeah have a nice day